so we like the master and we get ready
to call everybody we do the master angle
he comes in does it the same way
so now i'm thinking oh boy all right
how to get the best out of your actors
you know uh directing actors is i think
the
i would identify as the most important
responsibility of the director
uh of course there's many many other
things one is responsible to as they're
responsible for as the director
but to me the well let me read when i
wrote yeah your book is written okay
this is my book great directing great
television and i have a chapter on
um
directing actors which is a
the second longest chapter in the book
the other is on the language of camera
but um
let me just read the opening of it and
then i'll maybe take off from that and
summarize some of the things i do
discuss but i write i start the chapter
watching a great performance take shape
is one of the true thrills of directing
something emerges that is deep and
revealing about being human
helping your cast get there is among the
director's most important
responsibilities
some projects are more actor dependent
than others
but in my experience a story's impact is
directly related to how much
truthfulness emotional honesty and depth
of understanding the actors bring to
their performance
that's not to say that every character
is truthful honest or deep quite the
contrary
but actors who have accessed those
qualities in themselves
are in a better position to enrich the
story and i think that's so true because
i know as as i'm watching something it's
like if i know if i feel the actor is in
touch with something true and
interesting if i'm drawn to that actor
because there's something compelling
about who they are because they're fully
online let's say fully in touch with
something deep that they're working with
the story i mean that's that's what i
think typifies almost any great
performance doesn't mean they're intense
it doesn't mean anything else they could
be putting up a front they could be you
know disaffected characters but there
but there's an inner life that leads to
that kind of expression and the actors
need you know the best performances are
those who've filled in that inner life
so that it's coming it's like
a deep well of of experience that just
manifests in this this one way as
opposed to saying well i'm disaffected
so i'm just going to be disaffected i'm
not going to feel anything
you know you you might be feeling a lot
of work not to feel something as opposed
to just not feeling something
so
getting the performance is is is a great
responsibility and a great experience i
find and every actor is different
uh you know every you know
many directors are frightened of actors
they they feel like they're different
species well they're not they're they're
human beings you know there's there's a
whole range of cliches about actors that
they might be narcissistic or
self-important or overly dramatic or
whatever and and you know some of them
are just like directors you know just
like anybody
but really what your job is as director
is to
help the direct help the actor uh
be able to utilize their particular
process how they work and so that it
involves kind of reading each human
being that you're approaching to direct
for who they are and how you can connect
to them it's a very
intimate
intimate experience and i found
you know it's a big big topic and i
can't you know i i but i you know i
think that some of the things i can just
briefly touch on is
i think first of all uh
you need to develop trust
with an actor because you're asking them
to you want to share you want them to
invite you into their process
you know so so if they don't trust you
they're not likely to do that so in in
to be trustworthy i find you also have
to be as authentic as possible
so i try to because i want an authentic
performance from them also so i have to
you know if if nothing else i have to
model that i'm willing to be authentic i
want you to be willing to be authentic
and it also helps to it helps to elicit
trust
um different actors need different
things you know different you know
actors you know some sometimes they need
to be acquainted with the imaginary
circumstances sometimes they haven't
defined what's at issue in a way that is
consonant with your understanding of the
story or
they haven't enriched their character's
inner life as much as you'd like them to
do so sometimes you're involved in in
helping them with that the one thing
you don't want to do is
is to tell them
exactly how to do something and there's
a there's a kind of a just become kind
of a bromide about don't give result
directions meaning like
do it angry well you know
you might want that to be the ultimate
outcome of their performance but you
know you're cutting them off from their
impulses you have to give them a reason
for why you have to justify that because
you want it to feel like real human
behavior
the other thing about telling an actor
how to do something
is you're you're communicating to them
that you don't trust their own instincts
you know and that's that's the worst
thing you know it's like what i'm always
trying to do is
is to uh
invite the actor to explore themselves
and make it truthful for them i'll try
i'll do whatever i can to acquaint them
with what what i'd like them to explore
but you know
if they're not
connected to an inter and inner to their
own inner resources
then you know you might get them to do a
particular moment the way you tell them
to do it but what about the next moment
you know and and and also they're
probably not connected to their scene
partners because they're thinking about
doing something a particular way
and you know it's when when actors
aren't connected to their scene partners
you generally feel it it's hard to fake
connection you know you want that kind
of moment-to-moment connectivity
uh
and you want to provide
then another thing you want to work on
with actors it's always very helpful i
find uh you know there's a there's a
cliche about uh that people have a lot
of fun with with the actor saying what's
my motivation well yeah you can have a
lot of fun with that but the reality is
that's kind of the key question an actor
needs to ask and also a director needs
to ask
and actors need to be aware
i like to think of
think of it this way that it's important
to know a character's motivations
on a lot of levels of the character's
own awareness for example
example i said in the book too it's like
you know if uh if a
character wants to uh impress his boss
or her boss
it may be that's one level of a motive
but it may be it's really his father he
wants to impress in a deeper level so
that you know there's gradations of
there's depths of intentionality
what are some of the other things uh
another thing is you have to be willing
to
um take responsibility in a way you have
to be you have to be willing to deliver
a note that might not be easy to do
if you're going to ask an actor to
change the way they're thinking about it
i mean it helps of course as i say to
gain trust to gain their good will
but often you know you you can be in a
situation where
an actor has made a choice that's just
not
appropriate for what you think the story
is
and one of the one of the ways i
approach that often
is
i try to share with the actor
where a particular moment in the story
is falling there is an example i
cite in the book from an episode of
homeland i directed called 13 hours in
islamabad which was a very intense
episode
and i was working with mandy patinkin
who is one of the most intuitive
sensitively attuned actors with whom
i've ever worked he's very method and
he's very goes in deep place within
himself and
and mandy will actually say this early
in his career he was often pretty
intractable and was not very open to
directors giving them advice about that
he said i know how i want to play this
he's he's mellowed a lot in that regard
and as as it's been brilliant in
homeland
well in this particular episode um
let's see what's happened leading up to
the scene is there's uh
the the
the isis has kind of taken over this as
it overrun the packet the american
embassy in pakistan killed 37 americans
it's a complete disaster and the reason
they were able to do it was because saul
mandy's character uh had been captured
by isis and uh
he had been used as a bargaining chip to
draw out the forces from uh the embassy
to
to affect the prisoner exchange
so
isis
knew and that's i don't think it was
called isis in the show but a stand-in
for terrorist organization uh
knew that the embassy was not
sufficiently guarded
and then they had gotten other
information so it and saul blames
himself for having gotten captured
because he was inattentive he did
something he shouldn't have done he got
oh he got lured into a trap that he
punishes himself for not having figured
out
so it's the night of it's the night of
this thing it's just happened it's a
complete disaster everybody is in their
own personal crisis and
uh
saul is being debriefed by rupert
friends character um
i'm blanking on his character's name but
uh
so rupert is interrogating saul and
carrie claire dane's character is
watching the interrogation
and it was a very intense uh six or
seven page sequence uh i asked for an
hour i asked for a rehearsal in advance
of the call time because i knew there
was going to be a lot to really work out
moment to moment so i asked for an hour
long i mean people who do features might
think an hour that's nothing but
if i could get an hour that was that was
it would have to be enough
so i asked the actors to come in an hour
before crew call and we'd try to work
out you know all the nuances and uh so
the shape of the scene was that uh
rupert who has witnessed his compatriots
executed and is is just in a
mania of trying to capture haqqani who
is the lead terrorist
he's got to have something to go on and
he's he's interrogating saul what what
did you see when you were in captivity
you know give me something give me
something i've got to find this guy
and saul is bereft and he's he says i
didn't see anything i was hooded the
whole time he said okay well and and the
windows are blacked out and and
rupert says well what about the phones
the cell phones that they gave you says
they were changed out every day i don't
know what telephones
and
rupert gets
furious at saul and yells at him is you
have to do better you have to stop give
me something give me something and
mandy's reaction in the first rehearsal
was rage
he just
stood up to rupert and just yelled how
can i see how could i know what i didn't
see and he yells at him and and manny
patinkin is capable of unbelievable
power and fury
now what's supposed to happen at this
point is
claire danes is supposed to enter she's
outside of this uh
this safe room it's glass walls but she
can't hear what's going on but she sees
what's happening and she comes into the
room and she says to rupert friend we've
got to talk and they'd go outside
so we we rehearsed the scene and i knew
that mandy had made this choice he preps
very hard and he thought a lot about it
and i knew well
it's powerful it's legitimate he's
punishing himself for you know he's very
upset with himself it's legitimate in
terms of his character choice but it's
not right for this moment in the scene
because for this moment in the scene
the story point we're trying to give the
audience is that rupert
has become so monomaniacally attached to
vengeance
that he's becoming
a bit inhuman himself and he's going to
take
some terrible risks both for himself and
for others
in this episode and in future episodes
so we wanted to cue the audience to
this happening to seeing what's
happening within him and
carrie intervenes because
she has seen
rupert
rupert's excessiveness how he's hitting
a man when he's already down
but but saul wasn't down mandy wasn't
down so i talked to mandy and i knew
this is going to be difficult because
mandy is likely you know feels very
strongly about this and i don't want to
throw not that he wouldn't be
cooperative he would have wanted to do
it but i didn't want to throw a wrench
into his performance i didn't want to
cut him off from his instincts
so i said to mandy uh
here's
here's our problem i understand that
what that's another thing i do when i'm
trying to make adjustments that
i want an actor to feel seen i want them
to know that i saw what they were trying
to do there's nothing i think it's
dispiriting to tell an actor yeah i
don't do it that way do this way they
may have given a lot of thought to what
they did they have made and they're
and most of them are not stupid people
and if you don't acknowledge what you
saw them do and just say it doesn't make
you writing them wrong it's just a
difference of opinion
so what i'll tend to try to do is say i
see what you were doing how you were
trying to affect your scene partner in
this particular way i'd like to i'd like
you to think about this in a little
different way and i'd give them
different imaginary circumstances hoping
to kind of
orient them more towards what the story
needs to be
with mandy i told him i said
you know here's our problem it's very
justified what you did for saul's
behavior but it's not the story point
and i told him the story point is as i
just stated that we've got to feel that
rupert is hitting you when you're down
if you stand up to him with such
ferocity that we've always expected from
you
you might your rage might outstrip his
and we wouldn't get that feeling also
with carrie coming in
it's going to render that whole thing
differently motivated it's going to be
confusing
and i saw he understood oh that's the
story and it's interesting to me also
that it's not the actor's
responsibility to know how their choices
are affecting other story lines or other
characters that's your responsibility as
a director
but then what has to happen is
you need to find a solution that upholds
the integrity of all the characters you
can't then ask somebody to play play it
falsely for your character just so this
happens that's not good directing you've
got to be imaginative enough to find a
way to suggest
a way that they can identify oh i see
that would be a legitimate choice too
so i told mandy this i said you know
as near as i can recall by season four
we had never seen mandy
filled with any kind of serious
self-doubt or doubt in his own powers or
his own you know
fierceness
and i said you know i think what would
be
very moving here would be if you
if you're willing to go to a place of
deep deep depression like a real dark
night of the soul if you really can take
in
that your inattention
led to
a slaughter of 37 human beings and the
loss of all of the american contacts
undercover context throughout pakistan
if you can not forgive yourself for that
if you can just be constantly
punishing yourself internally for it
that you don't have to fight at this
point to oppose him
that would do several things it would
make his relentless attack on you
a very different matter and would
highlight
what's happening within rupert's
character
so if you're willing to consider the
scene that way i think i think we've got
it and he took it in
and he understood it and because i think
he understood the story
he was able to adjust his own
performance and what's so
fascinating to me is when you deal with
really wonderful actors and you appeal
to them this way they become
collaborators and can enrich your
thoughts your ideas beyond whatever you
might have thought of in a later scene
because of this particular note he had
taken in he found the most poetically
beautiful way to play a scene he was
taking a shower
and he just water pounding down on him
he just chose and he just chose to just
stare right down at the floor as water
is hitting him
and it's like you know it was so
beautiful and so poetic and i knew mandy
had
taken it in and accessed his incredible
resources to really
find the depth of uh
the depth of the scene
so as you said letting them feel seen
knowing that you that you saw them that
you saw what they were trying to do and
it wasn't necessarily a bad thing but
how about we try this and this is
something that this is always done in
private or just time not allow for that
well
no that is something one has to be
sensitive to that you don't want an
actor to feel shown up but generally i'm
hoping yeah and i'll try to of course
give notes whenever i can
sonovoche or in private but sometimes my
note giving is actually giving a note to
another actor who's hearing it
so sometimes it's like i want it to be
public because i want everybody in the
scene i might take it as an opportunity
to define what the scene's about
and i know that it might good actors are
kind of hearing that they might play
into that that's again enlisting their
cooperation and listening their talent
to they might find other wrinkles in the
way they're going to do so some so often
i like giving a note publicly because
i'm really addressing everybody because
i'm talking about bigger issues
so so that's that's one thing but i will
say
there are times when uh
it's
it's a little concerning giving a note
especially when you're dealing with like
an intimidating actor and i had one
story again i relate in the book
that uh just show us your book it's got
a beautiful cover thank you
it's directing great television inside
tv's new golden age
there was an instance where i took a job
on a show which will remain nameless not
because i think the actor would really
mind the story i'm going to tell but
i just want to be cautious on it he was
an actor very famous actor and i i took
the job primarily to work with him i
thought oh my goodness i you know he's
he's i've been blown away by his
performances and so many things
and
when i was prepping another thing i'll
do with actors is as i try to avoid a
situation where i'm showing up on set to
direct them never having met them
because it's like that's that's one of
the really interesting uh challenges of
directing series television is you're
the one temporary person and yet you're
in command you're coming into leading
and being the final arbiter and when the
performance is good enough to say cut
move on
and they may not even know you or know
anything about you or know you know it's
like how can i trust this person do i
know they even have a grasp of the show
you know so i try never to it doesn't
always work sometimes you can't meet
everybody before but i try and prep to
go introduce myself maybe talk a little
bit about the script if they're lead
characters
try to acquaint them with the fact that
i know
that i've seen the show and talk about
what i've admired about them and all
that and i'll also say while on this
subject often when i'm giving notes to
actors on show new or shows where i'm
new and they don't really know me
i'll try to couch my adjustments by
referencing other shows other of their
performances so they see i said you know
this moment is interesting it reminds me
a little bit about you know that moment
in season two where you had that scene
with so and so there's a lot of
similarities to that in this this moment
here where you know your intention there
was more this kind of thing i think
that's kind of more what's at play here
than you know necessarily trying to do
this other thing but the difference is
and you know so suddenly they're hearing
me oh oh they've watched both shows oh i
get okay i think it can build trust
but uh in this instance i went to uh
introduce myself to this lead actor i'll
call him i call him the book i call him
max so i'll just say his name is max
and
i went up to him and i just it was one
of those things where you're talking to
kind of a you know an i uh someone who's
kind of a acting hero of yours and
you're you know he's and i said oh i
really am looking forward to working to
you and all that and as i'm talking to
him
he had this manner of this kind of
preternatural calm he was just so
self-possessed so unaffected by anything
i was saying he just was looking at me
and i felt like i felt like i was being
looked through you know and i felt like
what am i doing here i'm trying to
impress somebody or it's like he's he's
not impressed and he didn't it was very
unforthcoming he was polite but you know
so i left it was one of those instances
where you think oh my god what did i say
was it that oh my god that was stupid
you know so i didn't feel the comfort
you hope to get when you're introducing
yourself
and so i went through my prep and then
the first scene we had together
was uh
the scene i was really looking forward
to him doing
because i oh he's gonna kill this it's
to be great
and
we rehearse it and
he comes in
and he gives the most tepid
uninteresting
performance imaginable worse it was
boring
and i'm just watching this
and what
and i think to myself okay
just remember this is just a run through
this is a rehearsal maybe his process is
not to act at the beginning you know
maybe it's okay and i don't want to be
you know come to him and say
max i think he's what are you talking
about it wasn't
what are you judging me for it wasn't my
performance i didn't want that right so
i said i'm going to just wait and we'll
shoot it and then i'll see what he
brings so we light the master and we get
ready to call everybody we do the master
angle he comes in does it the same way
so now i'm thinking oh boy all right
so now my first scene with this guy i
have to go to him and completely tell
him his instincts are completely off
from what i want
and i'm thinking and i'm also not sure
what he thinks about me you know
and uh
so i'm thinking okay what can i do now
so i think hard long and hard about it
and for the viewers to understand
the note i gave him i have to just tell
you a little bit about the scene
max's character was the leader of
a band of renegades thieves wasn't james
gandolfini this is not the sopranos and
uh
and he's a fierce
ruthless character
and uh
the person he's coming in to see
is someone and he has his own community
of thieves they have a their own world
and the person he is coming in to see
is someone who had an aristocratic
background who had to flee
because he was at his own trouble and
had sought refuge with max's world and
has been there now for several years
and uh what he's tasked with the the
other guy is tasked with doing is fixing
a piece of machinery that max needs
fixed
to accomplish his grand criminal scheme
he this has to be repaired for him to be
able to do this thing and he comes into
the scene and he says how is it going
and the other guy who also is sickly so
he's not very well but he says this is
really i don't know if i can fix this
it's really difficult
and max then begins to spin the tale of
their history and he says you know when
you first came here
i thought you were
you know an aristocratic
man who really looked down on people
like us you know rough young men who
kind of brought ourselves up by our own
bootstraps and all that he goes on a
little more he says but as the years
have gone by you know i've i've seen
that you know
you've uh you've assisted us and all
that
and i really hope that you'll
you know
work harder to get this done
that was paraphrased of what happens and
what max had done is he had taken the
surface level of the dialogue literally
and he played it very docily
respectfully and come in and said all
this thing very you know
nicely and inviting him to really work
harder
and
i went to max and i said
okay i said
i wonder if i could ask you to think
about this scene a little differently
uh
the contempt you describe having felt
for him when he first
arrived
i'd like you still to be feeling exactly
the same thing
oh look i didn't say it any more than
that but the anyway so i'll say so he
just looked at me and said
very well
and i go back to the
to watch it and we say action as soon as
he comes in there was just an electric
vibration
it was chilling it was terrifying
he came in and he started to talk to
this guy how is it coming
and then he starts to tell the tale of
their history and what you understood in
the subtext is
i thought you were an entitled [ __ ]
then
and i still think that
and just because
we've existed coexisted because there's
been mutual benefit
if that mutual benefit should ever end
your life isn't worth a cent
and that was this i mean this intensity
he had it was just terrifying he was
always just toying with him
and talking about it you know and it was
everything i thought the scene should be
it was just electrifying it was
fantastic
you know
so
we cut and we move on and we you know
play the scene no nothing more from from
max i do that max that was great thank
you whatever and uh
and so a few days later i'm in the uh i
do i do my laundry at the at the
costumers the wardrobe trailer where
they clean their clothes there's washing
machines i bring mine in and they throw
it in and the head costumer approaches
me and said hey i was talking to you
about i was talking about you with max
and immediately i'm a little unalert
because i'm thinking i have no idea if
he agreed with my note or what he thinks
about me or anything so i said
and she said
yeah he says he loves working with you
you're the first director to give him a
note
and i just
realized that you know other directors
great direct great actors might rarely
need notes but sometimes they do and if
you're the storyteller they almost
always will will benefit from shadings
or something to kind of you know point
them more but i think his his presence
was so intimidating to some directors
they just felt
i'm that's above my pay grade i actually
heard one director actually said that
and that's irresponsible it's tough but
you got to be willing to
stand up for what you think the story
point is and find ways to do it that you
know and take a risk you know maybe
someone you really admire is going to be
really unhappy with you and yell at you
but you know that's the buck stops with
you